make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay here's the thing about michael
korvac and here's the thing that that
people usually tend to either not know
or tend to forget so michael korvac and
the corvax saga that took place in the
Avengers was not really designed to be
that way right it was essentially a
last-minute decision made by Marvel
Comics and the reason why is in 1975 and
giant-sized defenders number three there
was a story called games god Ling's play
I think as what it was called it was
basically the defenders themselves now
at the time the team was composed of
Doctor Strange Nighthawk who was
actually a character from squadron
sinister who the defenders had
previously defeated and then in turn
Nighthawk was brought over to to the
defenders themselves as well as The
Incredible Hulk daredevil I think he was
involved in the story I don't know if he
was part of the team Valkyrie and and so
on but the idea here was to write this
story and just have like the defenders
facing off against various villains that
were brought in by the Grandmaster the
notion behind this was that if the
defenders lost then the earth would be
enslaved if the defenders won then the
earth would go free and so of course the
defenders won and so as a result of that
during that story michael korvac was
introduced as just a guy who was born in
the year 29 77 and that was it he was
his eye and he was just kind of designed
to be there for the sake of the story as
just a villain created by Steve Gerber
in order to tell the defenders tale and
then that was it the problem with this
is that by the time you got around to
1977 with Thor annual number six you had
Lynn y-you had Roger stern and these two
guys between the two of them especially
coming off the tails of giant-size x-men
number one Len Wein was supremely
popular now of course he had like
created Wolverine and things like that
and he had a lot of riding under his
belt but giant-size x-men number one I
think was really the story that kind of
they kind of blew him off but the idea
behind this was it at the time Marvel
had this comic called Marvel presents
right and this was basically an
anthology series of books right so like
the old school action comics where
basically it's a comic book it has a
whole bunch of different stories in it
so you had like like issue number one
back in 1975 and I think it was in
October of 1975 brought in Ulysses
bloodstone so you had John Warner who
wrote it you had Steve Gerber who wrote
it but at the time really in the later
half of 1977 Rogers Stern was writing it
and so with mall presents at that point
in time you had the guardians of the
galaxy really the the guardians 3,000
more or less is what they were who were
brought in and who were essentially kind
of an ongoing theme in the the Marvel
printed stories and were relatively
popular I mean they weren't huge I mean
they weren't super hot but I mean they
were created by Archie Goodwin Lynne
wine and Marv Wolfman ultimately they
were cancelled after 12 issues so it
wasn't really all that popular they were
relegated to Marvel
but the Roger stern wanted to take the
character of Michael Kovak who we
thought was interesting and who he could
do something with and then throw him
into the comic but the issue is that it
was cancelled before he could do
anything with it and so following that
you ended up having like the the
Avengers stories as they were being done
by Lynn wine at the time I think and so
the goal was to basically take Michael
core back throw him into the Avengers
stories and then we got the core back
saga and so you didn't really get much
of an ordinate ory until you got to the
corvax saga right I mean it started in
Thor annual number six but basically it
ended up extending out into the Avengers
between issues 167 168 and then 172 177
I want to say 169 was an interim story
but essentially it's just the corvax
saga which was written by Jim shooter
and David McLean II and so it was it was
it proved to be one of the most popular
stories at Marvel had right like the
corvax saga set the stage for Secret
Wars in 1984 fillin you guys who don't
know like it's a it's a pretty
significant event but the way has played
out was Michael Kovak was a guy from the
31st century or the 30th century or
whatever he was from the year 2900 a
little after 3,000 to be precise and
essentially at that point in time like
earthen and really like the the Saul
system had been conquered by the badoon
and so the result of this is that it was
a pretty harsh kind of militaristic
environment but Michael Kovak was
effectively like an enslaved human and
the result was that during his job he
fell asleep and and what they ended up
doing was basically blending his
physical body with computer technology
essentially turning him into a cyborg
and so what this did is it allowed him
to essentially analyze everything he
came across right like any and all
information could be analyzed by him and
turn he could you know achieve a
multitude of different goals this
eventually led to him showing up in the
modern day and in analyzing the ship of
of Galactus which basically granted him
the power cosmic in the process and as a
result he essentially started to go
insane well maybe insane is not really
the right word maybe that's really not
the right phrase here um technically
speaking he was kind of time-displaced
right like in the in the corvax saga the
way that Jim shooter and them kind of
got around and sort of incorporated what
Roger stern and Len Wein did is they
came back and they said okay so like
what was going on at the time was that
the michael korvac that we saw in the
original defenders giant-sized defenders
number three story was one who was
yanked through time by the grandmaster
to engage in that fight right and so
after he was defeated i think he went
back to his own time but regardless he
ended up showing up in in the earth-616
universe right you know in the main
Marvel Universe and that's when he
scanned Galactus his ship and this he
went forward and had the power cosmic
but what he ended up doing was meeting
the daughter of the collector
a woman to by the name of Karina and the
two of them actually fell in love now in
the guardians of the galaxy movie you
guys would recognize Karina really in
guardians to as the chick who grabbed
the power stone I don't really know what
the relationship is between her and
collector and the guardians of the
galaxy film it's never really explored
she seems like more of an office
assistant than anything else but
regardless during the core back saga the
two of them actually end up falling in
love and and she starts to sort of
sympathize with him and it creates kind
of a softer side but ultimately this
ends up with all the various superheroes
facing off against core back who's
wheeling this power of Galactus and in
turn two starts like killing everybody
right I mean like it seems like there's
no real way to stop him ultimately what
ends up happening after killing like a
multitude of different heroes easy
basically reverses everything he'd done
after he realizes that Karina doesn't
really sympathize with him anymore that
shouldn't really like him anymore and
ultimately sacrifices his own life why
does kind of dispersing his essence
across the cosmos and just kind of going
out with a big bang it was the only real
way to end the story right I mean you
know back in then it was it was common
practice for writers to write themselves
into a corner and then try to find some
way to end a Jim shooter was especially
bad about that but what it did is
basically kind of set in motion this
idea that like the power cosmic could be
stolen if a being was of sufficient
power or had the technological means to
access it and so when you take that you
kind of go forward this sort of
hackneyed explanation about about
michael korvac i feel like we should do
a full on michael korvac explained video
right so we can cover like more stuff in
detail but when you look at that for
what it is what you're talking about is
somebody who stole the power of Galactus
or at least who copy the power of
Galactus and then went forward as a
villain right so it really kind of
speaks for itself and this one reasons
why I kind of held off on you know too
powerful for Marvel movies Michael Kovak
because it would be like what if
Galactus became a bad guy with like all
human intent and emotion and ended up
fighting all the superheroes he would
kill them all like they would all be
totally obliterated at me at the end of
the day Michael Kovak image his own life
he wasn't defeated by anybody in
particular because he was just so vastly
powerful with someone like that you
can't really incorporate them into the
Marvel Cinematic Universe because what
it does is it elevates them to a level
of power that's so extreme that there's
no feasible way for them to lose
writers there's no real way that they
can be defeated it's the Matthew Molloy
concept
Matthew Malloy was a character who was
introduced by Brian Michael Bendis and
he was astronomically powerful so
powerful that he couldn't be stopped and
the only way to really stop him was to
travel into the past and stop him from
being born now that was Brian Michael
Bendis being Bendis and just kind of
hand waving away and that's kind of what
bindus does but with regards to again
putting micropore back in the MCU again
it speaks for itself you know somebody
walking around with what's essentially
omnipotence right like an insane amount
of power you know the ability to like
create and like there's one point where
he fights Starhawk and he actually kills
Starhawk he disintegrates him and then
reconstitutes him and takes star Hawks
ability a way to recognize michael
korvac right there's one port where
michael korvac restructures his entire
body to appear like a perfect human I
mean there's all these things like in
terms of how he he he believes he should
appear there's all these crazy displays
of power that you see when it comes to
his character and so somebody with with
the ability to create worlds and destroy
worlds to resurrect people from the dead
you know with all this kind of stuff
essentially the power of like cosmic
entities you can't really put him in the
MCU now having said that and I probably
should backtrack there you could but it
would require invoking characters that
haven't really been invoked before
michael korvac was equal to Galactus in
power and that was really kind of it but
there are other curators out there who
are far more powerful or equal to
Galactus in power right so you could do
the core vac saga proper but you would
have to have introduced characters like
the molecule man Owen Reese you would
have to have introduced characters like
Franklin Richards the Celestials could
do it assuming the Celestials and the
movies are on par with their versions of
the comics you'd have to have cosmic
entities right so like eternity infinity
The Living Tribunal may be introduced at
that point you're talking about more
power than you need to defeat Michael
Kovak I mean just a really strong
earth-based character could do it right
so like the molecule man right I mean
before his power was reduced he fought
to beyond her and they created like
shockwaves throughout the entire
multiverse because their battle was so
intense so you would have to have some
pretty powerful characters in there some
pretty heavy hitters to introduce
Michael Kovak into the MCU as it stands
right now nobody's powerful enough
either that or you're talking about
Michael corbat showing up and basically
taking what was equivalent to the power
of Thanos and then using that coming for
but it defeats the entire purpose of the
corvax saga
right I mean the purpose of the corvax
saga was basically a human who is now a
cyborg getting the power of essentially
one of the most powerful beings in
existence and then in turn going forward
and just you know kind of becoming a
villain and it was really more of like a
character tale right the rise and fall
of Michael Kovak so again it could work
but you would need a lot of heavy
hitters in order to pull that story off
because the reality is that it wouldn't
really be believable that's what will be
the ANU Avengers the offenders without
spider-man which good luck selling that
um but but essentially you'd have like
the New Avengers and nobody would
believe it if they somehow successfully
defeated this guy right because there's
no Tony Stark to hell
think they're way out there's no Captain
America no Steve Rogers to rally them
together
maybe Falcon can do it we don't know
enough about his character or how his
characters gonna evolve to know what
kind of role he's going to play Jane
Foster would be a cool heavy hitter but
she's not powerful enough to stop
michael korvac Captain Marvel certainly
isn't I mean there's really no one there
who could who could go on par and defeat
this guy what it would ultimately boil
down to is some entity outside of the
main characters of the film The Avengers
basically or even the x-men defeating
Michael Kovak you know he would
basically be these guys can't do it on
their own let's grab something else
instead now it would be a cool way to
introduce cosmic entities to present
Michael Kovak in such a way to where he
is a far more dire threat than Thanos I
think would actually be pretty cool I
would like to believe in the future of
the MCU Thanos does not work Pete but
he's only the top villain were ever
gonna see and like everybody's just
second to him after that you know that
would kind of suck like I want to see
that villains get more and more powerful
and more and more dangerous right like
Dragon Ball villains basically you know
but but it's it's kind of cool like it's
it's interesting insofar as his
character and what he can do but as far
as the Marvel Cinematic Universe goes
he's just too powerful for it is you
know in its current form there's no way
it would work you know it would take
cosmic entities or some beings of divine
power in order to basically take him out
but without being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here - comments explained to make
sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the robb core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]